[Musique]
survivant de l'holocauste
il ne passe pas inaperçu lorsqu'il est
visitée gymnase qui porte son nom
vous êtes les joueurs viennent tous dû
serrer la main
[Musique]
cette enceinte du quartier
côte-des-neiges à montréal a été
construite en 1999 grâce à un don d'un
demi million de la famille rights la
renommée du gymnase dépasse largement
les frontières du québec on produit
c'est le champion du monde empreint d
ici le manque était haché d'olympic
martine dugrenier triple champion du
monde et louis vi et saori médaillé
d'argent aux jo d'atlanta pour ne nommer
que ceux là même le combattant georges
st-pierre a pris ses techniques de lutte
ici vous entraîner la mort mais avant de
devenir mécène george wright a dû trompé
la mort il est né en hongrie en 1932 en
1944 sa famille et lui sont internés au
camp de concentration d'auschwitz en
pologne
là-bas et les séparer de sa soeur et sa
mère qu'il ne reverra jamais c'est un
combat chaque jour pour vivre sans arrêt
pas sans manger
c'est difficile mais c'est possible
son père lui a sauvé la vie en lui
offrant des rares portions de nourriture
rennais s'étaient déjà costaud à 12 ans
ils travaillaient 14 heures par jour
avec les adultes
ap est en débat il émigre au canada en
1948 grâce à un programme pour orphelins
c'est à ce moment qu'il découvre la
lutte
il a été champion canadien mais a raté
les olympiques de 1956 en raison d'une
blessure
l'année suivante et les porte drapeaux
du canada aux jeux maccabi l'équivalent
des olympiques pour la communauté juive
la lutte était faite sur mesure pour lui
en 1956 changera ni fond jean marc une
entreprise de fabrication de meubles à
terrebonne il a fait fortune et avoir
une entreprise en 2010 contribuent
maintenant chaque année financièrement
au succès de jeunes athlètes comme linda
mort et qu'elle aimait nager de windsor
en ontario à montréal pour s'entraîner
avec un jour affirme qu'il ne pourra
jamais rembourser au complet ce que le
canada lui a donné en l'accueillant mais
avoir la reconnaissance que lui porte
éditeur ce qu'il a donnée a su faire la
différence
ici en 3d et radio canada montréal